the Joe Rogan experience so three-fight
deal was on the table and Roman Gonzalez
surrett Sakai or surrett Sukhoi sir it's
a chi soaring visa we're getting ready
to fight their rematch at the Home Depot
Center I think it was September 9
September 6th that was a win today I was
supposed to be in LA that you know
announce the the new signing and get
ready to call that fight that Wednesday
I come home and I'm kind of like I'm not
fooling but I'm in tears and I tell my
wife I was like I want to do it anymore
and even saying that sounded crazy to me
she was like she was just real quiet I'm
thinking like why she's not saying that
they're like I hope that I'm gonna do
this anymore and she said something she
had never said previously typically
she's like baby look it's not time come
on you got to get up I know you feel
this way I know you're bi but come on
you I feel like you still got time in
the sport first time she ever agreed
with me she was like I think the
decision is already made during what she
I think the decision is already made she
said I've been looking at you throughout
this whole day and some of the stuff
you've been saying and I've never really
seen you like this
she said I think it's already made I
took that out bro started making phone
calls call call my lawyer who's you know
one of my good friends Josh Dubin say
hey bro I think there may be it for me
and he had been wanting me to be you
know done he was like if you feel that
way Bramah support you call my manager
the next morning and it took us so I
went I went I went that weekend and
called the fight we held off on the
announcement and my lawyer just told HBO
like look he's going through some things
we're good give us a couple of days so I
got through that weekend and he said do
you still feel like that come Monday
morning like brought think I'm done long
story short we ended up announcing it's
September 21st it was like a two-week
period we were trying to keep it under
wraps but I was undoing all the stuff I
was letting the necessary people know
rock nation HBO everybody know and the
night before I announced it made me and
my good friend who's a director he's
also directed my doc Deonte Thompson he
we put together this video it was like a
legacy video where I had my young son my
middle son and my oldest son and those
are like those were like you know that
was me at that point in time in my
career
here and we did this whole video that I
was gonna announce my retirement with
and and actually have the dock that I'm
working on right now is about this like
why did the best fighters the world of
the world at that time walk away from
the sport on top shot that video out men
the day of my retirement bro and the
response was just overwhelming you know
it was over when like I just couldn't
believe the amount of people that were
reaching out and it was it was like good
and bad like it was good because I was
getting support but it felt like
somebody died like I felt like I died
bro
I'm looking at his rest in peace like
not literal rested pieces but like the
comments were like rest in peace like
bro I couldn't manage blood like Ward
not you man oh my god man and it was
just it was like just this huge reaction
and it was overwhelming um and in the
two years that followed like I said at
the beginning of this podcast harder
than I thought it was gonna be one of
the hardest if not the hardest thing
I've ever tried I had to do and still
like I still have to do like it's a
daily decision that I have not do it no
more
but one of the most rewarding man and it
was a necessary evil and I hope that one
day man the young guys can look up one
day and say I'm gonna do the hunt reward
I'm done I'm out like how long do we
have to do it before we feel satisfied
look bro save your money if you don't
you're not financially literate go get
some help ask questions and as soon as
you feel like you're not really there
you want to do it no more I don't know
son said bro there's other stuff you can
do hope to be an example in that area
well it's so important I think for there
to be a guy like you because people
always have this narrative fighters
always come back they always fight like
Sugar Ray Leonard did when he fought you
know later in his career when he fought
doors on Iwo lon then he went and fought
yeah the Terry Norris fight was hard a
wise man and then you know it Hector
Comacho stop yeah yeah I mean it was
like you can watch it come out so good
punch either it was this calf was all
[ __ ] up then the Billy Blanks were
training them you remember that yeah I
mean it's just sad when you see these
guys to still try to do it over and over
and over again until the same story
keeps repeating itself
a guy like you it was only Hagler before
you
Hagler was only the only guy leverage
louis - oh that's true Lennox Lewis is a
handful yes a handful yeah Lennox it was
a brilliant guy too you know it's like
please chaps he's articulate he's it's
like he's an interesting intelligent guy
that just said that we're good we did
everything we need to do we did
everything we need to do having those
guys like you is it's so important for
young fighters because they get told by
the by the [ __ ] you know hey you
know all fighters gonna wind up with
brain damage all fighters gonna wind up
going out on their back they're all
gonna wind up coming back after their
prime it's so important for guys like
you to say you know no that's you can
manage it correctly these are
shark-infested waters but if you stay on
the rocks and you do your due diligence
and you put in the work and your
discipline and you fight correctly I
agree with you so wholeheartedly about
appreciation of the Masters of a real
masterful boxer like when I always talk
to people about Floyd Mayweather they
talk all this [ __ ] he does this he does
that he's got all this money I go save
all that forget about his talking watch
how that guy fights he [ __ ] barely
gets hit he's been rocked maybe twice in
his whole career Maidana and Shane and
Sugar Shane Mosley those the only two
the only two guys have cracked him and
he blown up winning both those fights
he's a master masterful boxer and that's
what everybody should emulate this day I
mean I love the Arturo Gatti making
fights as much as anybody did but if
that was my son
I'd be freaking the [ __ ] out I'd be like
don't fight like that it's not worth it
I don't give a [ __ ] how many of these
drunken [ __ ] cheer you want they're
not gonna be with you when you wake up
in the morning your head is pounding in
your head well you have a hard time
looking at light when you you have to
have all the shades closed when the just
a little crack of light coming in
through the shade is hurting you it's
giving you a headache they're not gonna
be there with you when you're old so if
I just always put it like this and as I
said a lot of people down he said man
let me ask you a question he do this to
reporters and stuff like I'm not like if
there was an opening workout he knew it
was a particular reporter in there that
was you know writing you know talking
down against you know guys would go by
he was an actual question you
kids yeah you got a certain absolutely
if you want to just on the box and it
was two guys at the gym and one coach
said Amen I'm a teacher so not a hit and
not get hit period
III know this art I've mastered it and
I'm helping master it and then you got
this guy over here to see like man I'm
he may have to take two to give one but
look he's gonna be tough he's gonna be
durable and would you send your kid
weight and they go ah the first guy well
there you have it
[Applause]